you shouldn't swim in the ocean because
a shark might smell you
i want to do like
[Music]
pms is made up
myth tampons can get lost in the vagina
that is a complete and utter myth the
vagina is not that big
it can do lots of magical things but
it's not
that big i'm dr wendy goodall mcdonald
i'm a board-certified obstetrician
gynecologist and i specialize in caring
for humans with vaginas
i am dr kiara king i'm a board-certified
obstetrician and gynecologist in the
chicagoland area
and i see women throughout all of their
reproductive stages from
adolescence through menopause and today
we will be debunking myths about periods
myths from social media periods should
always last a week
a normal period can last anywhere
between
two and seven days so if someone has a
five day period
that's okay if someone has a two day
period that's okay
if someone has a six day period that's
okay it's all within the realm of normal
if we're getting past that seven day
mark if you're going into eight nine
ten days two weeks of full bleeding
that can be abnormal tampons can get
lost
in the vagina that is a complete and uh
utter
myth the top of the vagina is literally
almost like we call it an apex but
there's like a dome
shaped space almost and the cervix kind
of hangs
down into that space but that's it
it can't penetrate that tissue it can't
get lost inside of your abdomen
occasionally a person will come in
saying that their tampon is lost and
they don't see it and i don't see it
well you probably took it out or it fell
out
or it will be there kind of tucked up in
you know in a ball behind the cervix
but it can't get lost inside the vagina
the vagina is not that big
pms is made up hmm
myth who is saying this
it is not a person with a vagina saying
this it can't be
pms is very real it stands for
premenstrual syndrome
it encompasses both physical and
emotional symptoms related to
the period often the symptoms will arise
anywhere from 10
to 12 days prior to the period
depressive symptoms anxiety
stress just feeling not yourself or
cramping
headaches body aches very real
and some women even have something
called pmdd
which almost takes some of those mood
changes
to kind of the next level regular
exercise has been shown to improve pms
symptoms
birth control sometimes can help
sometimes it can make it worse sometimes
people can take supplements or
increase their plant-based component of
their diet decrease their simple sugars
it's so important to acknowledge that
these symptoms are
real so that people don't then feel like
there's something wrong with them
for having symptoms that are
physiologically occurring in their body
severe period pain is normal up to about
80 to 90 of women will experience some
period pain
but the thing that i look at most in
terms of quantifying pain
is how it's impacting someone's life is
it causing them to miss school
are they incapacitated and in bed
all day are they not able to be present
in their lives that is not normal to
be in such pain that you can no longer
function severe period pains
can sometimes be relatively genetic but
it can also be due to endometriosis
fibroids can cause severe pain you'd be
surprised how much menstrual discomfort
is also related to
constipation or diarrhea ibs symptoms
can
kind of coincide with menstrual symptoms
but i would definitely want a person who
is having severe pain
to see if there's a possibility for an
ultrasound or other evaluation
to try to manage that pain better our
lives are so much more than our cycles
and we should be able to do
you know our regular activities even
when it's happening
menstrual cups are one size fits
all menstrual cups are one size fits
most a person that's looking to use a
menstrual cup
may want to try one or two
sizes to see what fit is going to be
best
for them you may have to go within one
or two different brands
to find a cup size that is right for
your cervix and for your vagina there
usually are at least two to three sizes
within any particular company
if you were to give just the gentlest of
tugs on that stem
if the menstrual cup moved out of place
it's probably too big
if you feel that there's a little bit of
resistance and a little bit of give and
it doesn't seem to be moving
then it's probably a good fit for you
myths experts hear the most
you can't get pregnant while you're on
your period partial myth
and the reason why i'm going to call it
a partial myth is because
technically within a person's menstrual
cycle you ovulate
if you don't get pregnant 14 days give
or take after ovulation
your period comes the lining sheds the
hotel room is turned over and is
ready to receive a pregnancy next month
so when that period comes and when that
lining is shedding you should not be
ovulating meaning releasing an egg that
could be fertilized
however every person's bleeding is not
necessarily a period
i think a period tracking app can be
very helpful so if you
know really what your menstrual cycle
looks like and the timing
of it that can help determine if any
other
bleeding times are period bleeding or
not
i have no reason to tell a person to not
have
sex on their period again other than
making sure
if they're unprotected that it is their
period and that they're not gonna be
surprising themselves
in nine months take-home message
irregular
bleeding and irregular periods is not
birth control
having a regular period is necessary for
your health
i'm gonna take your your line dr wendy
i'm gonna go with partial myth
when young girls start um getting their
periods it's like a vital sign
that the brain is sending the proper
signals to the old reasons the ovaries
are signaling the uterus
to do what it needs to do so in
that respect it is normal to have
a period every month and there are a few
times where
it's not essential for example if
someone is on
a form of hormonal birth control with a
birth control pill you're technically
having a withdrawal bleed
and not actually a period that is
regulated
by the brain and the ovaries and the
uterus with something like an iud
the lining of the uterus becomes so thin
that there's really not much to shed
tmi because i'm a gynecologist have not
had a period in five years
that's fine but i have an iud that is
progestin containing
that is keeping my uterus nice and you
know thin the lining nice and thin so i
haven't needed this thing i bought it
i haven't even used it whether or not
you have a period
has to do more with who you are
as in what stage in your life you're in
whether or not you're on hormonal birth
control
and a conversation with your health care
provider because
either option whether you have periods
or don't
can be healthy and normal but it can
also be potentially very harmful to your
health
you shouldn't swim in the ocean because
a shark might smell you
i want to do like
[Music]
more than likely a person that is
menstruating will have in
a tampon or menstrual cup if they're
going swimming
even further decreasing the amount of
blood that could potentially
be detected so that's one thing two
sharks kind of hunt for their prey
and humans aren't typically shark prey
and so when they are looking for their
next
meal they are looking for very specific
like amino acids that they will be able
to detect
so it's probably safe to go out in the
water you know
if you're on your period but i mean is
that are people just swimming with
sharks these days just randomly i don't
know
and if there's like shark signs beware
of shark i'm probably just not gonna go
out in the water
anyway having a regular period
means you're fertile so first of all a
period
cycle it's normal for it to be anywhere
from 21 days
to 35 days day one to day one if they're
shorter than that or longer than that
then that's not necessarily considered a
regular period and it can
bring into question whether or not a
person is ovulating meaning releasing an
egg every month and you need to ovulate
and release an egg in order to be
fertile but there are other factors that
are involved when it comes to fertility
it's the
uterus and whether or not there are you
know structures polyps fibroids in there
that can impair
fertility what are those tubes doing
what's that cervix up to
you know is it healthy when's the last
time you had a pack a regular period
that falls in that kind of category
that i mentioned is suggested that a
person is fertile but it's just not the
end of the story
a person who is menstruating can spoil
food
by preparing it if you want to eat or
not you know what i'm saying like
no that is a complete myth
your menstrual flow has nothing to do
with whether or not you're going to
spoil milk or eggs that's not
a scientific phenomenon so
so i'm just gonna make my mac and cheese
and i'm keeping it to myself if you
believe that
dough will surprise canned goods will
not spoil
mayonnaise will not curdle in period
blood it's not unclean it's nothing
there's nothing
about it that emits anything that is
spoiled that can spoil things or that is
unclean or unsafe myths from pop
culture people's periods will sync up if
they spend enough time together
i had to actually do a little
investigation on this one because
my initial thought was that this was
true there was some research done
back in the 70s by a woman named martha
mcclintock and she did a small study of
about 135 women
and found some evidence that when women
are around each other in close settings
let's say a dorm
they're on sports teams together that
their periods were
starting to sync up and it was actually
dubbed the mcclintock effect
subsequent research has been done and
one was using
a period tracking app that had about
1500 women in the study
another was of about 180 plus or so
women in china that lived in a dorm
together and what those
larger studies found was that there did
not seem to be
a sinking up of cycles based on the
proximity that you were
to these other people so i think there
seems to be some anecdotal evidence
you know moms and daughters
sisters you know they're living together
but it seems
that there that it's more coincidental
that their periods just happen to be
occurring
at the same time versus syncing up
due to maybe hormonally mediated causes
periods are dirty periods are not dirty
menstrual blood is just that it's
menstrual blood it's a physiologic
process
it signals that a pregnancy didn't
happen
and it's getting ready to make that
uterus a welcome home again
potentially um and so that blood has to
go
somewhere but it's not inherently
dirty blood can potentially carry
pathogens viruses so we
certainly want to be um cautious in
terms of
how it's handled we have to manage it
just like we would manage
our armpits you know our underarms or
our breath and our teeth to keep
ourselves
healthy but not because it's dirty
people often feel the need to go on
overdrive when it comes to vulvar and
vaginal
hygiene and it's really not necessary
there's absolutely no need to douche
that could potentially disrupt
the normal vaginal ph which can make you
more prone to
infection so i would generally recommend
just a
mild um soap and water
externally on the vulva i usually say if
it's not hair bearing leave it alone
only women get periods humans
with uteruses and vaginas get periods
but that could be a trans man
that could be a person who is non-binary
blood comes out of uteruses cyclically
if a person is off of birth control
and within reproductive age and maybe
not cyclically if a person is on
hormonal birth control or has had their
uterus removed
but any human with the uterus and the
vagina can have a period
a period is a physiologic function
it does not define womanhood by any
means
the biggest takeaway i would like for
anyone watching this video to come away
with is that our periods are healthy
our periods are normal it's okay to not
have a period if you choose to not have
a period and you are
navigating that space with a healthcare
provider you came here
for this information and that
is probably the biggest step that you
could have taken if you ever had
concerns
getting this education is going to
empower you
keep learning about your body keep keep
desiring to understand
more about your body because ultimately
you know your body better than anyone
else
and so knowing your body being educated
on how it functions
is going to allow you to navigate and
understand your body going forward